wir koordinieren sehr flexibel weil wir
haben nicht einen punkt einsatz sondern
der strecke über den gesamten bezirk
aufgrund dessen ist eine große mobilität
erforderlich aber mit uns und
verbindungsoffizier schaffen wir die
einbindung mit dem österreichischen
bundesheer sehr sehr gut setzen die
prioritätenlisten und verhangen dann
sehr konzentriert an zu arbeiten
wir haben mit heute ca 80
mandeloperation 26 zum einsatz gebracht
in den vormittagsstunden und werden in
den späten nachmittagsstunden circa 15
uhr noch schweres gerät das
pionierbataillon 1 zum einsatz kommen
die motivation als solches verfahren
weil sie wissen um was es geht weil sie
wissen dass sie gebraucht werden und wir
haben sie bewusst aus dieser region
rekrutiert und natürlich hofft man muss
live
die lage ist sehr ernst aber durch das
zusammenarbeiten von allen
einsatzorganisationen haben wir die lage
derzeit voll im griff
das problem ist dass noch den massiven
schneefällen zunächst bis einschließlich
gestern von gestern auf heute ein
massiver einbruch gekommen ist mit
schnee schneeregen regen
das heißt der schnee ist derzeit
ziemlich nass und das bedeutet ziemlich
schwer und die auswirkungen sind auf die
diversen dächer von altbau werke
katastrophal
diese findet man sehr sinnvoll von
bundeswehr in der die menschen hoffen
die man jetzt eingestimmt bevor es doch
eingehen oder so was zu einem jahr
drohen schöpfen snow
das klärt sich heute also in österreich
das marathon hüpft